foreign
is a village within maharashtra an
indian state with one of the highest
crime rates in the country
but the community of about 3 000 people
in this village worship a hindu god lord
shani
and they believe shani will protect them
from all harmony
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
me
they look like something out of an
indiana jones movie
bridges made out of living trees
this is nongriet a remote village in
northeastern india where locals have
been growing bridges for hundreds of
years
the head of the village
he's lived here his whole life since
1952.
thank you
foreign
to get the roots to grow into a bridge
across water they use wire and old tree
trunks to guide their path
foreign
foreign
16
years
foreign
ashika lee
is a motorcycle mechanic in pakistan
he works in an area where owning a car
or motorcycle is out of reach for some
residents
but ashik found a way that he could help
for the last 10 years he's been giving
rides on the back of his motorcycle to
anyone who needs one
for free
foreign
foreign
but at first people were skeptical
to gain their trust a sheik's best
friend zafar gave him the idea to play
recordings of the quran from his bike
now the two friends ride together
picking up passengers wherever they go
foreign
bye
bombay is
is fast
very chaotic
everybody's on a mission
and there is no
moment to pause
the taxi is essentially i think they're
quite like the heart line of travel in
mumbai
people from all cars community takes the
taxi that's why i felt that it was truly
like a mass communication medium
i'm sankethlani i'm a designer art
director i'm based in mumbai
design as an industry here is still very
new it's it's naive and the value for it
is very understated
i wanted to design a taxi and that's
where the project started
putting art in in the public space like
a taxi can exist as a storytelling
medium
i think a lot of these social issues
that exist today in india and even in
mumbai continue to exist because of lack
of communication
and at taxi fabric we decided that we
would work with designers who sort of
invested their time in coming up with
design solutions for social good
we've done a taxi with road safety
learning the indian sign language
being more inclusive towards students
with special needs
roshni desai we worked on this taxi that
talks about women's rights
today you talk to people they're like oh
yeah women has her place and a man had
his role and that's how it is and that's
how it's going to be but no one really
asked why
the question here is
which means
do these rules apply on men as well so i
just want to just stop that thought even
if it plants a seed
even it sparks a discussion that's fine
these conversations about social good
it can lead to a change of of mindset
we've tried to communicate through
design we've tried to do it in a medium
that is you know almost like an
equalizer
all of these conversation starters sort
of amplifying through
taxis will eventually at least ask the
right questions
if this gets the right support i feel
that it could it could lead to social
change
you